we know that the greatest risk to the
progress that we've made is the
possibility of another new variant
especially one that can escape immunity
and puncture the protective wall of our
vaccination program
we've always known
that variants have had the potential to
knock us off our course
and we've built the capacity to identify
and to respond to those that pose a
threat
the vast majority of new variants
present no risk whatsoever
since the summer there have been
hundreds of new variants but only one of
them
omicron
has been designated a variant of concern
we acted early to slow its spread
strengthening our testing regime and
placing 11 countries on the travel red
list
but despite those swift steps
the data over the past few days
has shown more calls for concern
and i'd like to reinforce with the house
today
to all honourable members why omicron
represents such a risk
to the progress that we've all made so
far together in the last week we have
been able to determine these things with
a high degree of confidence first that
it is more transmissible omicron is more
transmissible than the delta variant we
can see that the growth in omicron cases
here in the uk is now mirroring the
rapid increase that we are seeing in
south africa and the current observed
doubling time is around every two days
although yesterday
we reported there were
4713 confirmed cases of omicron in the
uk
the uk hsa estimate that for the number
of daily infections was 42 times higher
at 200 000
scientists have never seen
never seen a covered 19 variant that's
capable of spreading so rapidly so we
have to look at what we can do to slow
omicron's advance